[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled highly efficient
therapeutic antibody development
Solutions this webinar is a part of the
fifth annual event in the bioprocessing
virtual event series I antonina Salo of
labroots and I'll be moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by labroots and
sponsored by genscript for more
information about genscript please go to
jscript.dll
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click submit we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the
presentation you will also notice that
the speaker has provided a survey
located to the right of the abstract
this survey will be available during
both the live session and the on demand
period if you have trouble seeing are
hearing the presentation click on the
help desk button located within the
navigation bar or from the lobby of the
event finally as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your
credits I now present today's speaker
Amanda Grim senior segment marketing
manager at Jen script USA Inc for
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the presenter tab from the menu at
the left of your screen Amanda welcome
you may now begin your
presentation thank you so much hello
everyone and welcome um as mentioned my
name is Amanda grim and I am the senior
segment Marketing Manager for antibody
Therapeutics here at genscript my
presentation today is titled highly
efficient therapeutic antibody
development Solutions
in this presentation I will provide you
with an introduction to gen script
discuss what are antibody drugs outline
the development workflow highlighting
gen scripts end to end Solutions at each
stage and then I'll wrap up with a
summary might have to edit that
out um for those of you not already
familiar with Gen script we are leading
Global synthetic biology company with
offices around the world including
Oxford the Netherlands Singapore China
and Japan uh we were founded in 2002 in
Piscataway New Jersey here in the USA
offering the first custom Gene synthesis
platform last year we celebrated our 20y
year anniversary commemorating our
growth as the Gen script group as the
Gen script group adding subsidiaries
like Legend biotech that specialize in
Cell Therapy Uh custom array which is
our Seattle based aligo and production
array facility and our cdmo gript probio
as we've evolved we've also added our
catalog products division where you can
find automated instruments and ready to
use
reagents so let's get started and talk
about what are antibody
drugs antibody drugs are are based on
the magic of our own immune system
whereby we produce and engineer
antibodies to treat or modify disease on
the left you can see the types of
antibodies our immune system naturally
develops the antibody drugs are highly
specific to their target the most common
type being a monoclonal antibody as
development proceeds monoclonals are
modified in order to improve function
and this can include a number of
different format modifications we can
see some examples down here on the right
uh one of these is an antigen binding
fragment or Fab their small format makes
them great for either therapeutic or
diagnostic use one popular Fab
therapeutic is used for preventing uh
blood
clotting we're starting to see more
complex formats like the bispecific t-
cell engager referred to as a bite these
are popular formats in cancer
Therapeutics and are bispecific
monoclonal antibody that have two
different targets where one is for the
CD3 receptor on te- cells and the other
is tumor
specific another type of complex format
is the trifunctional antibody this
targets three epitopes and we're also
seeing these emerge in the cancer
therapy development industry as
well
looking back at the history of antibody
therapy development the first FDA
approved antibody was approved in
1986 since then there was a slow
progression uh between then and 2006 uh
whereby after 2006 the FDA started
approving new antibody drugs on an
annual basis in
2021 the FDA approved its hundredth
therapeutic antibody and I'm sure we're
all familiar with this one as it was the
monoclonal uh antibody therapeutic for
SARS K2
infection here we have a table of the
top 10 FDA approved monoclonal
antibodies the leading drugs Target
cancer and are seen highlighted in red
these include treatments for melanoma
coloral cancer and non- hodkin
Lymphoma not far behind cancer we have
therapies for autoimmune diseases these
are shown in purple treatments listed in
this table include rheumatoid arthritis
uh psoriasis and Crohn's
disease a smaller percentage of
therapies cover other issues such as
bone loss or infectious
disease uh I want to share one newly
approved antibody that came out in
November 202 22 I'm personally really
excited about this one since type 1
diabetes runs in my family it is an
autoimmune disease that attacks the
insulin producing cells in the pancreas
uh where the disease outcome is that the
individual eventually becomes uh
dependent on insulin
injections this MB treatment targets the
CD3 receptor on te- cells in order to
reduce the affector function of the
immune attack by those autoreactive te-
cells when it's administered to early
diagnosed patients the treatment has
shown to be able to delay disease onset
for as long as 25
months so let's take a look at the
workflow and what goes into the
development of antibody
drugs antibody drug Discovery is the
process of identifying and developing
antibodies as therapeu therapeutic
agents in the treatment of various
diseases the process involves the
identification of Target antigens
selection of appropriate antibody
formats optimization of antibody antigen
interactions and rigorous evaluation of
safety and efficacy through the
preclinical and clinical
trials the goal of antibody drug
Discovery is to develop safe and
effective drugs that can selectively
Target and neutralize those disease
causing agents while minimizing of
Target effects here I've created an
illustration of the overview of the
development broken down into these four
stages and in the next slide we'll
discuss some of the listed uh
development issues that researchers May
encounter so I've highlighted some of
these as barriers uh where gen script
can help provide a solution for uh
notably achieving sufficient quantities
of the target protein and achieving
sufficient selectivity and specific spe
ificity of antibody drugs um in these
next few slides we'll go through the
workflow stages um independently and
then we'll discuss solutions that will
help make your Discovery and development
more
efficient so starting with Target
identification the goals in this stage
include understanding the disease
mechanism selecting the therapeutic
Target and then validating the
target I've listed out here the
different areas uh Gene analysis protein
analysis and cell-based assays uh that
gen script can provide solutions for
your project I won't be covering all of
these but we'll highlight a few of our
most popular Solutions um a RH reminder
as we get into the discussion if you see
something you're interested in and I
don't cover it uh please don't hesitate
to reach out uh made sure to include my
contact info at the end and uh we can
also take questions
afterwards so starting with Gene
analysis many of our customers utilize
the gene Titan oligo Pool Service
because it allows them to screen a large
number of genes at the same time the
oligo pools are mixtures of oligo
nucleotides which can be designed to
Target specific genes or Gene families
researchers can knock down the
expression of multiple genes parallel
which can help to identify which genes
are involved in a particular biological
process or the disease
State they can also be used to perform
genomewide screening allowing for the
identification of Novel targets or
Pathways that may have been previously
considered using olal pools can be more
efficient and coste effective than
screening
individual sorry Gene knockdowns
especially when a large number of genes
need to be
tested okay some researchers run into
issues expressing their target proteins
our protein expression service will help
ensure that your protein is expressed
insufficient amounts whether you use it
for antigen for antibody generation or
for Downstream screening these proteins
can be produced using a variety of
expression systems including bacterial
insect or mamillion cells for in for
in-house analysis we also offer gels and
blotting automation
as fundamental tools for protein
detection and
Analysis this includes the blotting
units membrane processing instruments
electroforesis standards and high
quality antibodies for screening from a
personal standpoint anytime you can
automate Western work as a must I've
spent a number of hours and time in my
career uh making gels dealing with
uneven transfer and millions of trays
and tubes just for staining
as part of the target validation process
cellular analysis is commonly used to
clarify the target role in a signaling
pathway or its ability to B
Lions as stable cell lines are a
valuable tool in antibody drug Target
validation that provide a consistent and
reliable source of cells that Express
protein at a known level this enables
researchers to evaluate the function and
identify potential drug candidates that
selectively Target the
protein our cell line Solutions include
a collection of ready to use stable cell
lines or we have the capability to
develop a customized line specific to
your project we offer hundreds of gpcr
options uh most of the immune
checkpoints for cancer therapy develop
development uh various SARS kv2 proteins
and the cloud in lines as well
so once we've identified and validated
our Target we now move on to generating
and optimizing our leads in this stage
our goal is to generate a number of hits
identify those that bind our Target
through screening and then optimize our
most promising
candidates this slide shows the
comprehensive list of gen script
Solutions in this area so let's look at
a few of our key products and
services Mouse homas are the traditional
method of generating monoclonal antibody
hits they are still the most common
approved therapeutic our mono express
service provides multiple options to
generate high quality leads in as little
as 13 weeks we've made this very simple
and all you have to do is provide us
with your target sequence we'll take
care of the protein expression we'll
prepare it and we'll immunize the mice
our mono boost immunization is an
optimized technology that will expedite
your Homa project compared to the
standard method generally eliminating
about 3 to four weeks of development
time we offer two additional methods of
antibody lead generation using B cell
screening and cloning that improves the
timeliness that you achieve usable hits
our monor RAB monoclonal antibod service
uses the rabbit immune system to
generate and isolate B cells post
immunization rabbits are a known and
often preferred uh animal for their High
affinity and avidity antibodies the
service line shown on the top is a
simple enrichment of antigen positive B
cells from isolated pbmc's that is Then
followed by screening and harvest uh the
high quality leads are then sequenced
and engineered for recombinant antibody
production to further expedite your
timeline we also offer the beacon system
in combination with rabbit V cell
Generation The Beacon allows for high
throughput screening since it can test a
high number of B cells and perform
multiple screens in parallel screening
that typically takes a week or more can
be completed in a day uh the high
quality leads from this uh testing is
their isolated uh sequence and then
engineered for recombinant an body
production for our customers who have
completed development to this point and
want to continue to do so on their own
we do offer do-it-yourself options for
purification systems that will allow you
to automate these processes our amag
assay provides High throughput antibody
or protein purification using the
magnetic bead technology it can it can
purify up to 12 samples and purification
is complete in 1 hour our newly launched
amag Quattro provides a high throughput
automated plasmid purification solution
the instrument has a modular capability
allowing you to add up to four
instruments that can be controlled from
one device the four modules can handle
up to six samples each totaling 24
samples that results in yields that
range from 3 micrograms to 1 and5
milligrams of purified
plasmine once you've identified your
antibody lead candidates optimizing will
provide several benefits in terms of
improving the
potency uh selectivity and pharmokinetic
properties of the drug which will
ultimately increase its efficacy and
safety in patients gen script offers
several optimizing capabilities
including antibody Affinity met ation FC
engineering stable cell line development
humanization and
more some of our further optimization
tools include our Precision mutant
libraries the libraries are a powerful
tool that enabled identification of high
Affinity antibodies with desired
functional properties the libraries are
created using site directed mutagenesis
to introduce a defined set of mutations
into the target protein or antigen which
can then be used to screen for
antibodies with improved binding
Affinity specificity and functional
activity Precision mutant libraries can
be generated for various targets
including the difficult to express
proteins and membrane proteins and can
be used in combination with our Fage
display Technologies for antibody
screening and
selection gen scripts turbo Cho platform
is a proprietary technology for antibody
drug development that utilizes a high
performance Cho cell line to improve
protein expression and
yield we have three different levels of
service that are applicable to the
different stages of antibody drug
Discovery the platform offers several
advantages over traditional chill lines
um this
includes higher protein expression
levels improve cell growth viability and
reduce production costs
in addition to the cell line development
the turboo platform also includes a
range of services for antibody lead
optimization that includes Gene
optimization Vector construction and
antibody engineering to improve the
Affinity
specificity and the other
properties having identified your leads
with high potential preclinical studies
are then conducted with the goals to
perform trials on non-human subjects and
evaluate efficacy toxicity and
PK my slide here shows the solutions
available at jscript including
capabilities to file and support you
through the indd
studies the products outlined in this
slide include our endotoxin detection
kits uh these are used to detect the
presence of various endotoxins that are
usually cellular or bacterial
toxins um these can cause inflammation
and other adverse effects in
patients the kits are important to
ensure the safety and quality of
preclinical research materials such as
recombinant proteins and antibodies We
additionally have an endotoxin removal
kit available as well um that one is a
column based kit that can be used to
remove the endotoxins prior to use in
animal
studies um gen script also offers a
variety of immune checkpoint protein and
antibodies which are essential for
setting the immune system and developing
immunotherapies immune checkpoints are
regulatory molecules that help prevent
overactivation of the immune system but
they can also be exploited by tumors in
order to evade the immune surveillance
by targeting these checkpoints
researchers can potentially enhance
the immune response against cancer and
other diseases our immune checkpoint
products include recombinant proteins
high quality antibodies and lits for
detecting checkpoint protein
expression our Probot team provides
comprehensive services to support
preclinical studies for antibody uh
antibody drug development including
Services related to the chemistry
manufacturing and controls or
CMC they offer a range of these services
including cell line development process
development analytical method
development and manufacturing of
clinical trial
materials their
manufacturing capabilities include
microbial
fermentation um mamillion cell culture
and protein
purification they use state-of-the-art
equipment and Technologies to ensure
high quality cons consistent production
of your antibody and other biological
molecules in addition to CMC and
Manufacturing Services the probio team
also offers a range of analytical and
characterization services to support the
preclinical studies these include assays
for protein Purity identity and potency
as well as stability testing and
pharmokinetic
Analysis the final stage is moving your
new antibody drug onto clinical
development the goal of this stage is to
conduct clinical trials in people
according to phases outlined by the
local regulatory body in the US the the
FDA outlines three clinical phases where
phase one is a small group of patients
and normal
volunteers data is collected to assess
dosing side effects drug metabolism and
pharmacogen
actions after passing phase one phase
two includes a larger group of subjects
and studying the effectiveness for the
indication identifying any short-term
side effects and also any
risks passing phase two moves to phase
three where an even larger subject pool
is studied for Effectiveness and
safety uh evaluating the risk benefit as
well as determining the basis of
physician
labeling
the clinical phase is complex and
requires strict regulatory adherence our
clinical development support is provided
by our highly experienced ddmo team at
Jens script probo they offer expertise
in cell Bank generation scale up Tech
transfer and Regulatory Compliance to
help accelerate the development of your
antibody drugs and ensure their success
in the
marketplace the cell Bank generation
Services include developing master and
working cell Banks ensuring Regulatory
Compliance and Performing extensive
quality control tests to ensure the
consistency and stability of the cell
lines in addition to the cbank
generation and scale up probio provides
technical transfer services to ensure a
seamless transfer of manufacturing from
the research lab to a clinical
manufacturing fac facility there's no
wait time to get started and they're
able to complete the technical transfer
within two months they work closely with
the clients to ensure that all Technical
and regulatory requirements are being
met that brings us almost to the end
I've covered quite a lot so let me run
through the next couple slides in order
to
summarize so let's review the workflow
ultimately we want to create an anbody
drug that's going to be safe and
effective it's common to counter
barriers along the way for example
screening a large group of potential
Target genes the protein purification
and Analysis and making sure you achieve
high quality antibody leads to solve
these in particular we looked at gen
scripts algo pools um the automated
instrumentation nrb cell sorting and
cloning options just as some
examples
here's the summary chart of our antibody
drug related Services some were covered
in my presentation today and some were
not uh you'll see um highlighted in the
chart uh the quality production levels
and capabilities for each service we are
quite flexible and at any point we can
easily adapt most of these as needs
change with your product or with your
project so this concludes my
presentation I want to thank you again
for your attendance I've included a QR
code to our antibody drug Discovery web
page and feel free to reach out to me if
you have any questions about what I went
through today or would like more
information in general thank
you thank you Amanda for your
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your
screen now let's get
started our first question here is can
you provide more information about the
custom cell line
development yes of course so for the
custom development we prefer customers
provide their own cell lines the service
itself includes DNA construction um
transection selection High producing
clones and then we'll follow that up
with um testing for the protein
expression stability and
functionality great thank you another
question here is what are the detection
levels of the endotoxin
kits great question so we do have both
qualitative yes no and also quantitative
versions The
quantitative kit yes quantitative the
quantitative kit plus standard so with
that you're going to generate a standard
curve and once you generated that the
kit can then detect a range between
01 and one euus per
Mill thank you our next question how is
the mono boost immuniz immunization
different from a traditional
immunization yes so the mon boo
technology is proprietary technology
developed here at
jscript um what I can say more about
that is that a typical timeline is that
that
antibody uh using the mono boost uh is
going to be ready in in about eight
weeks with this
option time for a few more questions
here um our next one is can I send my
already expressed and purified protein
for antibody development
yes definitely so we can we can generate
antibodies with your protein um but just
keep in mind it might change some of the
project timelines but
definitely thank you wrap with this one
how many samples can the amag do in a
day so with a normal work day you could
get a minimum of 60 samples and that's
based on on uh putting in 12 samples and
the fact that it can complete it in
about an
hour awesome thank you and thank you
Amanda do you have any final comments
for our
audience just thank you so much and as
mentioned we're we're here to make your
research easy so please reach out with
any questions that you may
have great thank you thank you again
Amanda for your time today and your
important research before we go I'd like
to thank the audience for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions I'd also like to thank our
sponsor Jens script for sponsoring
today's webinar questions we didn't have
time for today and those submitted
during the on demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration this webcast can be viewed
on demand for 2 years until April 5th
2025 and labroots will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
any one of your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time
goodbye